[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle cimino j'ai 30 ans
ça fait cinq ans que ficher style design
et j'occupe la fonction de manager d'une
équipe de designers pour laisser habiter
et les accessoires
m
j'ai fait une école de design industriel
avec l'option transporte dans une école
qui s'appelle strates à sèvres ce cursus
bien d'une passion depuis toujours pour
l'automobile et l'humilité du transport
en général
le sens de mon travail aujourd'hui c'est
d'arriver à ce que le client final qui
achètent une voiture comprennent et vive
le storytelling et pour les fonctions
qu'on a voulu lui mettre à disposition
par exemple sur certaine sérénité qu'on
a sorti récemment on a mais le client
final dans la peau d'un agent secret
[Musique]